One of the things we also should discuss is the terminology confusion about
the out of order processors and how we name different parts of them.
We have been calling the stages of the execution, issue was when we obtained
the reservation station and the A.R.B. entry. Dispatch was when the instruction
was selected for execution, and commit was when the instruction has committed.
This terminology was introduced in the original [UNKNOWN] algorithm and
then commit was introduced in the first paper that talked about [UNKNOWN]. So
most of the academics are going to use, this terminology, so
most of the research papers that are written will use something similar to this.
However, some companies and some of the papers, will for issue use the term,
not only issue, but also, allocate because, this is when we allocated resources
for the instructions. And so pretty much we allocate and then [UNKNOWN] and so
on. So they're going to call this allocating, sort of issue.
And, to confuse the issue even further, some call the issue part,
dispatch. So we dispatch the instruction to reservation stations and
the ROB entries. Similarly, what we have been calling dispatch,
some will call execute. Some will call it issue, so we issue the instruction
from a reservation station to execution, as well as our usual dispatch,
which is we dispatch the instruction to execution. And finally, the commit is
most often called commit, but sometimes, it's been called complete, which
introduces some confusion because actually the instruction completes execution.
Well before it commits, it's just that now, the term complete will refer to
commit if that is the nomenclature that they are using. And then, commit is
also often called retire. So we retire the instruction from the processor. And
because a lot of papers have been written by academics, especially graduate
students, commit has also been called graduate. You can guess why.